marc arazi quand on lit votre livre
aussi alors là et ça je sais que ça
intéresse tout le monde
on parle de la saint jean oui est-ce que
la 5g et plus dangereuse parce qu'elle a
5 g tout le monde en parle à 5 g
maintenant il responsable de tout alors
est-ce que la 5 g/l et elle est
dangereuse
elles continuent elles dangereuses que
dell et la 4g l'était la 3g n'est la 2g
en fin dé presse que jusqu'a ce qui est
plus problématique c'est que la salle
kléber a commenté le niveau de manière
significative mais le pire si vous
voulez c'est que les on ne sait même pas
encore mesurer la qualité des téléphones
portables parce qu'il ya les bancs
d'essai et les normes pour mesurer je
veux pas rentrer dans des dossiers dans
l'électro d'un arbre technique mais en
gros on ne sait pas mesurer le niveau de
7 nouveaux téléphones s'agit et dernier
point le sud c'est que vous savez que
l'état empoché 3 milliards récemment en
vendant les fréquences aux opérateurs
mais elle l'a fait avant même d'avoir la
position officielle de notre agence
sanitaire qui nous rendra son rapport
qu'en juin 2020 2021 donc la question
qu'on peut poser c'est est ce qu'on va
rembourser les opérateurs moi je crois
pas alors justement en parlant là des
téléphones des opérateurs tout ça est ce
qu'il y a un téléphone qui est sûr pour
nos téléspectateurs est ce qu'il ya une
marque ou un téléphone ou un smartphone
ou vous dites c'est sûr il paraît que
non non ce que j'ai vu en a pas alors
malheureusement non on vient par
téléphone sur le le le
c'est encore plus grave que ça c'est que
notre agence sanitaire donc il faut lire
le livre mais en gros on va forcer
l'agent sociales et des fréquences à
donner les résultats des rapports de
tests qui étaient gardés secrets et on
se rend compte si vous voulez que on a
tous été surexposés de manière de
l'hyper importante
je me suis perdu on voulait me reposer
la question c'est est-ce qu'elle est
téléphone sur moi j'ai ma rue et dont
ils ont parfois plus si vous voulez ce
qu'il faut voir c'est clank sait ce
qu'est ce qu'elle a demandé elle a
demandé à ce qu'on retire on en est bien
on retire ou qu'on mette à jour tous les
téléphones portables vendus avant juin
2010 est bon il ya le gouvernement
s'était engagé à ce qu' il ya une table
ronde avec les industriels et cette
table ronde débat n'a pas eu lieu
et aujourd'hui art
évidemment il ya la question du coc vide
mais en gros les le gouvernement
finalement va privilégier aujourd'hui
les intérêts des industriels par rapport
à notre santé est ce que vous dites ce
que vous dites dans le dos vote libre et
il paraît vous dit également que voilà
tout au long de votre livre vous
expliquez avoir tenté d'alerter les
autorités publiques et les médias en
vain ce sujet a même été classée
quatrième des sujets les plus censuré
aux états unis en 2018